hello everyone and welcome to this
uh webinar for the lab roots genetics
virtual week
this is anxima roy i'm an associate
professor
of pathology and pediatrics at baylor
college of medicine
and i also serve as the medical director
of cancer genomics at texas women's
hospital
uh the title of my talk today is
laboratory implementation of clinical
genomics in children
and i have no disclosures to make
so let me start with the objectives of
this webinar today if you're joining
this webinar
i would expect that you would have
after this session a good understanding
of the different
mutation landscape in childhood cancers
as compared to adult cancers
i would focus on describing the
structural variations
primarily fusion genes that drive
different childhood cancers
and uh i would show some examples of the
clinical implementation of genomics in
children
and how these can lead to a broad
utilization of these technologies
in the clinic and and provide useful
biomarkers for cancer management
so let me start with this one
introduction slide
that came out of a pan cancer study in
2018 these are landmark publications in
children
in childhood cancer by groping our tau
in nature
back-to-back publication showing the
different landscape of childhood cancers
in adult cancers at the top over here
what you see
is a plot of the number of coding
mutations in childhood cancers
in compared to adult cancer so on the
left you see pediatric cancers
they have a horizontal purple bar
indicating the pediatric cancers
and to the right of it you see all the
adults some of the adult cancers
marked with the green horizontal bar and
i think you can appreciate on the y-axis
the number of mutations
uh by different types of tumors are
being plotted and you can appreciate
by looking at that that in general
pediatric cancers have a much lower rate
of of decoding mutations
compared to adult cancers which have a
higher rate of choline mutations now
this is something that has been known
for a long time
and so this paper just merely
emphasizing that this is true
and significantly lower in pediatric
most of the pediatric cancers that were
studied
now having said that you can see also
towards the right of that horizontal
purple bar that some of these cancers
actually do can have very high rates of
mutation
sometimes even as high as adult cancers
to the right
and so these are often referred to as
pediatric high
or hypermutated or even ultra
hypermediated depending on the total
number of mutations
now if you look at the bottom you can
see the
the fact that the number of structural
variations in childhood cancers
so on the left you see the number of
structural variations by different
pediatric cancer type and you can see
that some of these
on the right again do have a high number
of pediatric
high number of structural variations in
their tumors and so adrenal cortical
carcinoma
and osteosarcoma and to the right of the
lower panel you can see
a plot a distribution plot of the type
of different mutation classes in these
tumors
so in green are cancers
that are driven by mutations these are
small nucleotide variations or indels
whereas the purple highlights the
structural variation or in this case
copy number
or other structural variations including
translocations that drive different
types of tumors
and you can see that there is a broad
category there are some tumors that have
both green and
and purple in those bars some tumors
that are completely driven by
uh green or mutations there are some
tumors that are predominantly are
completely driven by structural
variation
and so you can see that structural
variation plays a fairly important role
relative to mutations
in pediatric cancer so that's one
important take home message from this
and that also informs how we design
genomic diagnostics in children cancer
so
in this rational design it's very
important to integrate
multimodal diagnostics in this case not
only looking for mutations and small
small nucleotide variations but also
identifying the best methods for
clinical
diagnostics or structural variation and
often these are dna and rna sequencing
combined in the clinical laboratory and
i highlight rna sequencing and
and fusions and copy number as things
that i'm going to highlight in the talk
the methods need to be robust and
scalable enough for
fairly low quality specimens in the
pathology laboratory that are typically
ffp specimens or fresh formal and fixed
paraffin embedded specimens
and then um we are still trying to
figure out in the clinical diagnostic
space
which tumor and when and and and what
type of methods are best suited
uh in different types of tumors in other
words genome-wide testing versus focused
panels for clinical activity
so um i'll focus on structural variation
a specific type of structural variation
class
in in this case gene fusions that can
arise through different structural
variation mechanisms
the most common i would say the most
well understood is chromosomal
translocation
and so this is the prototypical example
over here of a chromosomal translocation
of one gene on chromosome
on the left the other genome chromosome
on the right
arises leading to a translocation so
that two of the genes in green
and orange come together in this
chromosome on the bottom
and these examples are well known and
widely studied and have been
known for like uh two days two decades
and sometimes three decades
obesity are able one in leukemia female
varia etv6 and drk3
classic examples however
it's important to realize that gene
fusions in in pediatric cancers or in
adult cancers for that matter can also
arise from different non-translocation
mechanisms and often these are
inter-chromosomal events
with between um different portions of
the same chromosome
and often they might be cryptic and not
detectable by other mechanisms so one of
them is an intrachromosomal deletion in
this case shown over here as a deletion
so in the on the left is a gene that is
colored in red so we'll call this gene a
and on the right is gene b in blue and
they are all both transcribed in the
same direction on the same chromosome
and a deletion can arise by
um break one breakpoint within the red
gene and one breakpoint within the blue
or the gene b
and that deletion can lead to these two
genes that are far away on the
chromosome to come together
and form a chimeric gene so this example
of this is several known
now i've given two examples over here
tmprss to erg in prostate cancer
and dna jb1 prkca and fibrolamellar
hepatocellular cancer
the second method that we know again
into chromosomal is an inversion
in this case the two genes are actually
having the arrows pointed towards two
different sites so they are
transcribed in two different
orientations away from each other
on the same chromosome now an inversion
mechanism would lead to
a change in the orientation such that
this genes now become in the same
orientation and have
portions of the red and portions of blue
leading to
again a primary fusion gene and so
example of this is an
mb2 statistics it's in a solitary
fibrous tumor
well-known sarcoma
there are also intrachromosome
duplication events that can lead to
these fusion genes
and so in this example you have again
two genes these are on the same
chromosome
and in the same orientation in this case
you have a segment
intervening between these two genes that
gets
duplicated or has a an extra copy form
and then that extra copy leads to
transposition of these sequences and now
you have two genes
coming next to each other which are
separated in space by circular bases so
this is an example of intracranial
duplication and
the best example that we know of is this
earache fusion that is seen in a
pediatric chemo called pallocetic
astrocytoma
so what are the functional consequences
of these
uh again these are a few examples uh the
classic example that i told you about
vcr able 1 and other fusions
is where gene a and gene b both provide
coding sequences to the fusion genes so
in this case gene a and gene b come
together
and by coming together they are offering
coding sequences both from gene a
and gene b so the protein that is made
is half
gene a and half gene b so this is a true
chimeric protein
but it's in the second example so this
is an example of ews r1
1 is a good example of the first type of
example
uh the second category over here is
where gene a
and gene b forms a fusion gene but gene
a does not provide any coding sequences
to the fusion gene so let's take a look
at this
in this case gene a has an untranslated
region
this untranslated region is the only
contribution of gene a to the fusion
gene in this case
so there is no coding sequence or no
protein
coming from gene a or gene b in this
case
is being driven by the promoter of gene
a
so this example where it's a
deregulation of the expression of
protein b
under the control of gene a promoter
is often known as a promoter swap event
and in this case a great example is
myosin heavy chain nine with usb6 in
nodular fasciaes
and then you have other examples where
it is not even a true
specifically a gene fusion what you have
is
a protein b or gene b is being uh
juxtaposed next to an enhancer element
from
gene a where the gene gene actually is
far away from the enhancer
so basically the enhancer is basically
driving this uh
expression of protein b an example of
this would be igh
mick uh this is a very well known
example in burkett lymphoma
so the models of this fusion and how
they derive cancer is
also falls into mainly two main
categories
one of them is called the unitary model
in which you have genia and gene be
fairly constant in terms of being seen
only with
each other or mostly with each other and
they are also very specific to the tumor
types they are seen
together and they are seen together in
the specific tumor context
the other example is modular where gene
a
and gene b whereas gene b is fixed gene
b can have partners
with a multitude of gene a's so you can
have gene a
type 1 gene a from a different
type gene gene a2 gene a and so on and
so forth so gene b
is in this case the effector gene
whereas it can be driven by multiple
different types of ga
and this modular unit is also very well
known and the frequency of this in
different tumor types can be variable
and this often we refer to as bucket
fusions
alk is a well-known example of this ntrk
is a well-known example of this
where these kinase fusions drive
different tumor types
so how would you do workup for gene
fusion so the classic
workup was based on cytogenetics this is
the legacy
method that is still used in some
context
uh it has fairly low resolution and
is not scalable at all whereas you also
have fish-based methods which also been
around for a long time now has
definitely high resolution and
sensitivity
and still not scalable versus the newer
age methods that we are
now speaking about in terms of genomics
where you use different types of next
generation sequencing methods either
dual anchor or single anchor based
methods
and these by far offer the highest
resolution
high sensitivity and also scalable if
not
the most scalable method right now
so in most academic and reference
centers
uh use of different types of
uh panels which are comprehensive panels
is fairly well established and some
centers might use even
more comprehensive including exomes and
genomes
for cancers but for the most part
clinical practice today is
uh is mostly utilizing comprehensive
panel designs
this is an example of how these panels
might look like there are genes often
that
are primarily there for the mutation
class that we've looked at
genes that are primarily there for the
fusion or structural variation class
that we looked at and then genes that
are there for both reasons
and this is an example of a panel that
is used in the clinical
diagnostics laboratory at our
institution
and so i'm going to share the for the
last uh 15 60 minutes or so i'm going to
now share some examples of the utility
of
applying such broad genomic testing in
different types of childhood cancer so
i'll start with some gene fusion
examples
so the first example of this is um
is an anaplastic epinema which is a
fairly well-known tumor type in children
has been studied
for in different types of uh in cancer
genome
catalog studies and epinema seem to
usually have
a particular type of fusion that is a
c11 of 95 with rev a
however in literally hundreds of your
candy moments that have been studied
the presence of anti-archication has not
been described
so here in this case what you can see is
a tumor
and in panel b up top this radiologic
image that you can see there are some
white arrows that are pointing to where
the tumor
is before the use of ntrk inhibitor
and then panel c you can see those same
white arrows showing
essentially dissolution of those white
areas that
are the the tumor foci
um you can see at the bottom this
this pathology image showing the tumor
and
and to the right of this these are the
ngs or next generation rna sequencing
reads that show a fusion between
a gene called cance1 to ntrk2 or in
track two
and so this is a relatively um
unusual finding first of all the fusion
itself is very rare described only once
or twice
uh this particular fusion interactor has
never been described in epidemic
however the presence of this fusion
fairly unexpected
did lead to an attractable target for
this patient
and this patient was treated with an
interact inhibitor in this
case and the treatment did
show a very good response and this
patient is actually doing very well
right now this paper is impressed right
now
i'll show you a second example uh with
colleagues at uh
across the street at md anderson this is
a
um now a middle-aged man who had
a lesion in the spinal area in the
vertebral area
and this lesion if you see on the right
was uh
was a huge lesion that was actually
completely
encompassing the the large blood vessels
uh leading to an inoperable tumor so you
could not really
take the tumor out without damaging
potentially some of these vessels
this tumor was then sent to us for um
clinical testing and we found
a different entrap fusion in this case
called lamin
alma with track one
and um if you see a b
and then c and d you can see a distinct
change between
a and d for example in air you can see
all this white space that is being
the tumor kind of getting into spaces
whereas post therapy in d you can see
that that tumor has fairly dissolved
and this patient got a vertebrate tummy
done
and is doing very well as well
a third example this is uh again from
our archives
a 16 year old female with a large
mandibular mass
it's a big white tumor that is arising
in this
radiologic image on the top panel in the
left
and you can see some pathologic images
showing expression of certain markers
that
that that indicate that this is a this
is a skeletal muscle tumor or
rhabdomyosarcoma
now when we did clinical testing for
this patient we found a
fuss gene fusion with an tfcp2
this is a fairly new tumor or new fusion
that has been described in the
literature
mostly in tumors that arise in these
bones
in this case mandible and this was a
it's a fake rare and totally unexpected
solution in this case again a great
diagnostic biomarker
and helps with the patient's clinical
management so these are some examples
of of fusions i'm going to
move on to show you an example of
a series of cases
where we looked at a different type of
alteration
and these would be classified as tandem
duplications
now canon duplications by themselves
are one of the most difficult
alterations that currently exist in
terms of clinical genomic analysis
pipelines because they
provide an unique challenge in terms of
mapping these
events to the reference genome because
there are segments that are duplicated
and they do not exist
on the reference genome so this is an
example of
internal tangent duplications in a gene
called b core or pcl
vcl6 core pressure
this is an old story we have published
this in 2015
along with several other papers coming
out from different parts of the world at
the same time
uh this is uh in clear cell sacrum of
kidney which is a
fairly aggressive renal tumor of
childhood these tumors arise in the
kidney
and often can not be easily
distinguished from a different type of
tumor
which called will's tumor and wild
tumors are often
do fairly well whereas these tumors if
not treated very
aggressively can lead to a very
poor outcome so diagnosing these tumors
are very important
however diagnosing these tumors are can
be very difficult a because these are
fairly rare tumors and not many have
experience with these
and b is because these tumors can come
in a variety
and multitude of different pathology
patterns so it makes it for a difficult
diagnosis for pathologists
in this case we had one patient that we
were studying as part of a large
clinical genomics trial
and we found this patient's normal you
can see on the
on the bottom panel where we show some
next generation sequencing reads
you can see that in this case in this
patient's normal blood
we found no mutations but in the
patient's
tumor we found the point mutation at the
stop codon stop
loss variant in that same gene so it's a
somatic
finding uh however stop-loss mutations
are fairly rare and if you see and look
at this pattern over here it
suggests that there is uh something
called a
soft clipping it's a bioinformatic
bioinformatic term highlighting
some sort of a processing
issue with mapping that is causing these
reads to be clipped
or partially removed so
this one this next slide can show you a
better
better image of this again on the top is
normal
on the bottom is c for tumor and you can
see on the left
that exact same image that i showed you
on the previous slide
however if you can unclip those so these
are soft clipped meaning these are
hidden
if you can unmask these you can see that
all of these actually have some
sequences after that
that we're not showing up on the left
you can see on the right
and so when you take those sequences and
you and you match them against the
reference genome you realize that these
are tandem duplications in which
uh if you look over here on the left top
you see that
b chord is a gene that has 15 exons
in the last exon of this gene you have a
segment
that is highlighted in green called p or
parental segment
just below that i show a parental
segment next to the red segment which is
the itd
or internal tandem duplication as you
can see that the parental segment is
basically duplicated in tandem or next
to each other that's why it's called
tendon replication
and so the reads that go from the
parental segment
into the duplicated segment these are
the reads that get clipped because they
are not supposed to have a duplication
over here
so once we found that we looked at all
the other clear cell sarcomas in our
archives and we found remarkably that
all of these tumors
showing over here in a gel
electrophorogram had an internal timing
duplication regardless of
of male or female gender
we also mapped out each of these
segments
green again at the bottom over here
green is
the parental 7 and red is the
duplicated segment and as far as you can
see there is a
common segment that is duplicated in
each of these tumors
but each of these tumors have different
tandem duplications
so given those were very novel findings
at that time now it is
it's a fairly established biomarker and
is studied by many groups
we also did some functional studies to
to identify
the effects of these in in b chord
expression
you can see on the top uh that the
presence of these
duplications or ipds led to a very high
expression of v-core
in these tumors whereas in similar
tumors in the kidney
recoil expression was very low except at
the end
you see a record cesium which is a
different type of sarcoma
but in this case instead of an itd it
has a weak or fusion gene
where also the expression might be very
high and on the right i
show some protein expression uh showing
that it's not just the mrna but peak or
protein itself
is also also highly expressed that led
to the use of b core antibodies in some
of these tumors and in the middle
section you can see that there are some
strong expression of the
car now
we went back to our bioinformatics
method of
identifying this and in published data
sets
where we did not have the actual samples
but we had published
and available data in repositories we
looked through all the clear cell
sarcomas that have been sequenced
as part of the target study in other
studies and we found the same
discordant main pairs that we have seen
in our tumors
also show up in these tumors so that was
a remarkable finding this is a
completely independent data set
not sequenced by us by other groups and
we were able to show that there is a
peak
near the b core x15 in every single case
that we looked at
so we realized that this was a very uh
classic
and defining mutation in this particular
tumor because we did not see this
mutation
in many other different types of tumors
and then we looked at
expression profiling of these tumors and
compared it to many other sarcomas and
other tumors
and we remarkably found that whether it
was a b
chord fusion with c c and b three or
whether it's a b chord itd
are these tumors all clustered together
at the center over here we can see how
this expression profiling
this this is a hierarchical clustering
unsupervised but you can see the ccs
case and the fusion positive tumors with
vcor
all clustered together neatly so that's
a remarkable finding
now we know about five or six years down
the line
that many of these tumors that we call
non-deficient
sarcomas and other tumors can have
both types of alterations defining this
tumor so this table over here at the
bottom shows
on the first column you have the
different tumor types
the second column shows the incidence of
b
core fusion in these tumors and then the
third column shows the incidence of
itds in these tumors and what we found
was that
somewhat interchangeably most of these
tumors can have either one
and so this is borne out by the genetic
and by the expression studies that i've
shown you so far
so changing gears over here for the last
few minutes
i'm going to focus on again an
unexpected finding but in this case
not of any particular mutation or any
particular structural variation
but in broadly of the mutation rate or
mutation load in a tumor
so we refer to this as hypermutation
this is one patient from our archive who
we published about a couple of years
back
this patient presented to our service
with um what is typically referred to as
a multiple
cafe all this pots and calculate spots
are nothing but
a portion of skin discoloration you can
see in in figure a
and figure b in panel a and panel b
you can see multiple areas of the back
of the head as well as the
the back of the patient showing dark
discolored
patches these are uh often referred to
as caffeiolic spots
and and in a patient with so many
caffeine spots
uh a typical clinical impression is of
potentially
of a neurofibromatosis or neurofibroma
but because of the presence of multiple
of these and the patient presented with
the large tumor which is seen in c and d
in the brain or is in the call the
the concern is always for a
constitutional mismatch repair
deficiency syndrome
in in in which you have bialyc
or two copies of your mismatch repair
genes
mutated in the germ line that's the
patient has inherited these two
mutations
so um in g h i and j
we show that by protein immunostaining
for this mismatch repair proteins we
were able to rule out
that there was no mismatch repair
mutations in these
patients uh so what could be the cause
of this when we did an explanation
sequencing panel for this
patient's tumor what we found was
a large number of variants in this
patient's tumor
and uh that would fit with a
tumor count or tumor mutation burden of
157
which typically translates to ultra
hypermutated tumor
and so ultra hypermutated tumor and i
already showed you that there are no
mismatched repair mutations
so this typically by doing mutation
signature analysis can be resolved
and so in our methods of mutation
signature analysis we compared our
mutation signature in this tumor
to the right to the published regional
signatures on the left
and we found what was a classic
signature 10
and signature 10 is typically associated
with
a germline defect in polymerase
mutation so for dna polymerase gene
mutations
and so here we show that we actually did
then go in and find
a polymerous e mutation in the germ line
on the top you can see these are
normal or germline and in the bottom you
can see tumor you can see there is a
mutation in pole e
uh the polymerase epsilon that would
lead to an alanine f456 being converted
to proline
this is a well-known hyper-mutator
mutation
in poly and the identification of this
led to not only the genomic signature
which led us to
do this mutation analysis but the
identification of the tumor mutation
burden
mutation signature and the poly mutation
led to multiple clinical management
decisions
that we made for this patient this
patient is now closely being surveilled
for early colorectal cancer and this
patient
tumor is considered sensitive to immune
checkpoint inhibitor
if this patient's tumor does recur
so i hope i was able to show you some
examples of unexpected
targetable prognostic and diagnostic
biomarkers that you can find by
broad genomic genomic testing in
childhood cancers
i showed you many examples of fusions
and other structural variations that can
often be sole drivers of these cancers
and of course there are many much more
work that remains to be done in
childhood cancer
especially in the clinical diagnostic
space
including identification of novel
targeted therapies
and further integrating multimodal
genomic sequencing techniques
so with that i'm going to stop here and
acknowledge the large group of people
who work in my
in my lab as well as the numerous
collaborators with whom i've worked over
the years
uh some of the some of the centers and
sites that have provided all of this
information for us
and um i appreciate your your attention
and um i hope uh you enjoyed this talk
and
please feel free to reach out to me if
you have any questions
um and that will end up this time thank
you